gary my instagram's so on fire it's so
awesome why is nobody like why am i not
gaining followers
because it's not awesome that which you
do not hate you will eventually tolerate
and i think that identifies most
people's lives
do you ever let yourself have a day when
you just watch netflix never because you
guys [ __ ] on netflix
i'm haughty no i can't do it wanna be
happy
build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn
how you can be empowered to do anything
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one take full ownership
with gary vaynerchuk so one of my
favorite
garyvee um answers was
when asked what you would do if your
daughter when she turns 14
goes into her room and is filming all
her videos and nobody likes it and she
comes out and says nobody in this world
loves me
and your answer was step your game up i
believe
tell us about that the market is the
market man like
like like you know if nobody's watching
your stuff like it's not good enough
like everybody thinks their stuff is so
good like every day
gary my instagram's so on fire it's so
awesome why is nobody like why am i not
gaining followers
because it's not awesome like of course
like it's just back to the state like
you've seen it you
all have friends who'd be like look how
cute my kid is and you're like uh
you know like like it's what we think we
all think our stuff is the best and like
i get that but yeah that would be my
advice only because
that also is liberating like peop like
to me everything's about breathing right
like to me
everything is about like take full
ownership for everything
and then everything gets easy because
then you're in control
and then learn how to love to lose like
for me my game's simple
right it's all my fault so now i'm not
mad at lindsay or drocker that's it my
fault
i'm empowering them so it's actually
true
my fault now oh we lost this or this
didn't deliver or we [ __ ] up
all right so now like everybody's got
losses you know it's funny
uh when ufc started getting popular i
started using it to paint the picture
i'm like look
business and entrepreneurship is much
more ufc than it is boxing
in boxing a loss is devastating
like you know if you ever you know if
you're i'm a big boxing fan like most
big fights
like the big big big fights through here
almost it's just unbelievable amounts of
33-0 versus 35-0 right just like
that's like what you do you don't fight
anybody and you get to that level
everybody's got losses in the ufc and so
i think that's how that's how
entrepreneurship that's how life is we
all have losses
and so i like losses i love adversity i
like the climb
i like the chip on my shoulder i like
when people are like oh i knew it he's
not that good that is like
like i'm even weirdly scared as i
continue to ascend and i'm getting
popular and what do you say the
marketing leading like
people start putting these words in
front of my name i'm like am i gonna
sabotage myself
to like re-correct this like i like
adversity
so yeah all on me
you know i enjoy losses now all of a
sudden like what you become completely
invincible i feel invincible i really
genuinely outside of the health
of myself and 20 people feel 100
invincible as a person rule number two
be fueled by
pain with ed my let there's a malcolm x
quote that you really like
tell me what it is and why it's so
powerful that which you do not hate you
will eventually tolerate
and i think that identifies
most people's lives in other words they
average becomes sort of like this slow
asphyxiation it's almost like an
anesthetic
and that over time we become kind of
immune and dulled to the average that
we're becoming i know this is true at
least for me you probably experience it
yourself too
and so over time we sort of minimize
where we're at in other words
i'm a little pudgy instead of being no
you're fat ass right you don't
magnify the degree to which the pain
ought to be affecting you
and so really what he means in that is
listen you're going to get out of your
life what you'll accept that's really
difficult for people i think to
understand is look what you think you're
worth and what you're going to tolerate
is absolutely what you're going to bring
into your life
and what the outward part of your life's
going to look like and so i live by that
like i let myself
sort of feel the pain and the difficulty
of
of being not where i want to be and
whatever that area is whether it be my
spirituality my relationships my money
i let myself feel that pain because as
you know there's two motivators right
there's the gaining of pleasure
right wanting to go get something
chasing the dream but then there's the
avoidance of pain
and for a lot of champions that's a
pretty big driving force for them and so
at least for me i i leverage
both of those things on me to get myself
to take action i love the book by my
brother evan carmichael built to serve
you guys this is the kind of thing you
get in this book
most people wake up and drive to a job
they hate think about your five closest
friends
are they happy do they live their lives
with purpose do you
we put on a fake front for what we want
people to see and think about us
but the reality is most people aren't
happy we're lost we settle
you can't be happy if you don't know
your purpose and then he goes on to
explain how to do that
you guys should get this book built to
serve by my dear friend evan carmichael
rule number three don't be mediocre with
david goggins
do you ever have a day where you just
think okay i can't be asked to do
anything i'm not going for a around i'm
not stretching
i'm doing nothing every day yeah
you say you have the thought but you
don't have the day every day don't ever
let yourself have a day when you just
watch netflix
never because [ __ ] on netflix i'm
hunting no i can't do it
i can't do it there may be some days i
get up with poopy pants
and i'm like you know what man this man
like what am i training for
yeah i have no race in the docket why am
i having this
this such a structured life why and i'm
like
you know what i'm good i'm done i retire
every day
yeah i'm done with this and i sit around
and say okay
and then this is my thought process so
you want to be normal
so you just want to be like everybody
else that roams the world
not knowing the power that's in them
being fine with being mediocre
you want to go back to who you were huh
david i don't like [ __ ] that man
and you have that conversation with
yourself every day not every day it's
those bad days yeah
it's those bad days i see a whole bunch
of people walking around out here
who have no idea how talented they truly
are now i'm gonna talk about talent like
some god-given ability
talent that sometimes you have to hone
and you have to work on
and you get to harness yourself and they
just walk around this
on their phones just clueless to how
powerful they are
rule number four break the pattern with
jay shetty we've all had the story and
i'm just sharing it again to give
context we've all had the story of the
two wolves or the two dogs however you
want to phrase them if you haven't
i'll tell it now it's it's a story of
how inside of us there are two dogs two
wolves
and they're fighting for supremacy so
inside you
one is the initiator and one is the
responder
your whole life you've been feeding and
listening to the initiator
so your initiating wolf is strong
powerful
bulky aggressive because it's been fed
well
your whole life and your responsive dog
your responsive wolf has not been fed
has not been listened to
and so it's weak and feeble and meek
and humble and doesn't even stand a
fight so when they two come to fight
inside of you
this this wolf's just gonna eat that
wolf right up and that's what's
happening right now so for all of us
whatever two wolves you're seeing
whether it's your mind and your
intelligence whether it's your
intuition versus what your parents say
whether it's
expectations of society versus your
expectations of yourself like whatever
two wolves you have inside of you
the one that wins is the one you feed
and the ones you
have been feeding now if you're at a
point where you are
and where i am and where all of us are
in different scenarios of our life we're
trying to shift and start feeding the
other one
it's hard because the other one's just
been fed more it's stronger it's able to
push
you it's able to dictate you and this is
where
detachment's so key that detachment
doesn't mean that you owe nothing
detachment means that nothing owns you
and most of us have become
owned by our darker wolves most of us
have become
owned by the self that we don't want so
so that conditioning has been drawn up
the only way to break it is to disrupt
the pattern to really
break that it has to be and this is why
i talk to people about immersive
experiences
like you meditate for 10 minutes a day
on a head space that's wonderful and i
recommend it
but that's not going to shift this in a
drastic way
you are going to have to go and spend a
week out in joshua tree with the shaman
you are going to have to
take a break islam jerusalem right we
were both in love with jerusalem like
instead of going on a holiday this year
you are going to have to go on a
three-day intensive transformative
retreat
and the reason why i'm saying all these
different things is they all have
different budgets they're all available
in different countries you don't have to
go to india and live with monks
but you have to do something and it has
to be immersive
because when you get immersed in
something then you're giving something
the power to break your pattern
right and i think the challenge is we're
trying to solve it
by a little thing every day which is a
good start to get us going
but if you're really serious about a
massive shift in your life
wherever you're seeing that energy
coming from for the right side the
responsive side yeah
you need to go water that you need to go
feed it you need and you need to go give
it energy and that's what i think
we find that and then that's why i think
people struggle they still want to go on
their beach holiday
they they're like no i can't give that
up i need that or
this weekend i still need to go and do
up my house and it's like well no
like just imagine what would happen if
this weekend
you just went on a three-day retreat
that changed your life like imagine if
you just
gave that energy and rule number five
the last one before a very special bonus
clip
is combined passion growth and
contribution
with brendan burchard passion plus
growth
plus contribution equals personal
satisfaction
yeah yeah it's like
those all coming together a lot of
people have never experienced
and it's hard for you and i'd say that's
personal development guys but it's true
there's a lot of people who've never had
those three completely line up so
they're not satisfied
even with their job or their career or
their life because the passion isn't
there
even if the passions are they don't feel
like they're growing but everybody i
talk to
do you remember that first personal
development book you read do you
remember that first time you wrote tons
of notes about what you wanted your life
to be about do you remember that first
time you watched a movie inspired you to
go change
there was fire there because that
learning
it opened up your mind to a new level of
existence for you
and soon as you saw it you were like oh
ambition hit your heart
and now if you can match it with
contribution and you can see
how that passion or that fire or that
learning or that growth all aligns to
some type of impact
now you're getting me fired up because
now i can see the
outcome of all the work a lot of people
don't do the work because they don't
believe the outcome that's interesting
you know if uh and psychologists talk
about the power of
expectancy um when we talk about
motivation there's only two things that
spark
motivation one is ambition and that is
i want more of or i want a greater depth
of
right i want a greater depth of
connection with my lady
that's ambition where i want a better
meditative practice that's ambition
all right i want to be better at my job
that's ambition so it starts with
ambition
but ambition if it's not coupled with
what they call expectancy in psychology
you're screwed expectancy says i believe
that i can figure that out i believe
that i can achieve that
i believe that that is possible for me
because if we don't believe it's
possible for me you can show them all
the results from a thousand people
right how many people say i want to get
in great shape you know
i'm tom i'm a new ketosis i'm doing the
ketosis thing man
and they they hop on your instagram and
but then they see they see
the cuts they see the changes they see
the transformations
but they don't believe it's possible for
them so they don't try
expectancy is their problem you gotta
bust through the beliefs to get them to
understand that it is possible for them
not for other people for them and if you
can open that gate for somebody
and often that's only achieved through
learning
then you get somebody who starts really
moving ahead forward
i mean really moving ahead like the
second they go
wait that's possible for me they'll try
50 stupid things
right they'll try anything but if they
don't lose possible then they'll just
quit
now i've got a really special bonus clip
on how to not stay
in mediocrity that i think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
question of the day i wanna know what is
the pattern in your life that you
need to break let me know put your
answer down in the comments below and if
you made it this far in a video you're
still here watching i want to celebrate
you because believe nation we don't just
watch videos we do
something about it so that's you and you
commit you promise you're going to take
action
immediately after watching this video
give me a hashtag believe down in the
comments and tell me where you're from
because i want to celebrate you if you
are the most ambitious person that you
know
you are going to play small for life
look around at your friends
your family the people that you hang out
with what do they
want out of life if you're the one
always pushing them
and no one's pushing you guess what
happens
you don't get the push that you need and
you stay in mediocrity
being the best in a group of unambitious
people so i just came back from an event
in florida that i was doing a keynote at
and
at the end i challenged an entrepreneur
who showed up to make some changes on
his youtube channel we met over dinner
i helped him with his youtube channel it
was him and his business partner sitting
there and i said by tomorrow
here's what i want you to do i want you
to go in and make sure you have
these things updated and he said yes
i'll do it i said it's important to do
it by tomorrow because i'm still here
i'm still here in the morning
if you need anything you can ask me face
to face while i'm still here before i
fly home to toronto
yes i'll do it next morning comes around
we show up at a meeting i got a meet-up
happening we got i don't know 30 people
who showed up to to meet with me
and i see him out of the corner of my
eye sitting at the back of the room and
i say hey
did you do the thing that i told you to
do they said
no i didn't do it i said why what
happened
i said well we were doing lots of other
stuff it's been a full day
you know we had this entire day of of
speaking and meeting people
and then so much information went home
we were doing all this kind of work
okay great but what about the promise
that you made to me to do it
and then his business partner chimes in
and said you know it's actually my fault
i told him
evan's probably not gonna notice he's
not gonna remember
don't worry about it we'll take care of
it when we all fly back home
and so i told him don't let your
business partners low standards prevent
you from moving forward on the things
that you said you were going to do
staying committed to the thing that you
say you're gonna do your word to
yourself
is the whole game forget about what you
just say to other people
what do you do for yourself because
we're often looking for knows we're
often looking for somebody else to give
us a break
right he's been working hard and and he
is and i know him and i know his
business partner
and these guys are not slackers they're
not slackers and
and i was poking a little bit at his
business partner saying his low
expectations his low standards but in
this situation
it was true the entrepreneur that i was
speaking to
said he was gonna do this thing by
tomorrow morning before he came and went
to my event
he would do it and his business partner
says he's not gonna remember
don't worry we've worked too hard
already let it go we'll do it when we
get home and they would do it when they
got home i know they would
he's looking for the reason not to do it
when you say you want to hit the gym
when you say you want to hit these
business goals when you say you want to
have this outcome and be proud of the
effort that you put in every day when
you say that you're going to do
something
there will be moments where you want to
let yourself up the hook where you say
i work so hard i'm so tired or i deserve
a break right
this is the language you use to yourself
and so when that happens you're looking
for affirmations from the people around
you
and if you are the most ambitious person
in your friend group
if you are the most ambitious person
what's gonna happen
they're gonna say you already worked so
hard anyway what are you talking about
yes of course give yourself the break
and it's the exact answer that you're
looking for because you want to give
yourself a break
now if you're proud of your effort maybe
you should take a break
but it's not because somebody with lower
standards gave you the pass
it's because you're proud of the effort
that you put in and so this is where it
gets really dangerous when you are the
most successful the most ambitious
person
from the people around you they're
always going to give you a reason to
play smaller
you can't accept it you have to push
through you need to change your
environment
if you want even more motivation to fuel
your life check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there you're gonna find peace from going
to war
with yourself whenever life will start
getting good for me
god would throw a nice anchor and stop
me right there